well like Mecca said thanks very much
for coming to the the hang of it
shifters this has been dubbed by my team
we really appreciate it and welcome so
we're gonna be talking
we're gonna be talking about making
manual how to make money on Google Play
so Google Play is this gigantic digital
marketplace so Android has way over a
billion users it will be 2 billion even
more users and Google play's how those
users get software and content so we
actually we view that as a very very
important responsibility and the way
that we make that possible is we built
this marketplace platform so that's how
we get all this to those users and for a
marketplace you need transactions and
that's what we three work on so we make
the Google Play commerce platform happen
so basically you can think of our job is
to make developers like your souls
successful we want everyone to be
successful selling content and software
on Google Play so I'm Alistair putz I
lead product for the Google Play
communist platform I've been a retail
guy all my life I started off in South
Africa where I grew up more recently at
Zappos or common at Amazon and I've been
at Google for like 3 years now and I
absolutely love it
I'll let the other two introduce
themselves hi everyone my name is Mecca
and I'm the engineering leader for
Google Play commerce I've been at Google
about three years and before that I was
at Amazon also big retail commerce nerd
there I built a little thing called the
Amazon App Store and before that I was
an app developer I had a company that
built a lot of mobile apps probably the
one that you've heard of most is I got
to go
so yeah that's me hi everyone my name is
Thames and Taylor and I'm the partner
development manager at Google Play my
background is all mobile content I've
been building and making money out of
mobile products for about 15 years
thanks very much so the commerce
platform one of our biggest strategic
pillars is reach like we have this
vision that every single person on earth
should be able to transact easily on
Google Play basically how do we bring
this gigantic gigantic audience or
markets to you
developers we have a big team working on
this the steam wakes up every single
morning they're out there right now
thinking about how we can achieve this
vision one of the best things that we
can do is support local forms of payment
so we've got this gigantic marketplace
way over 140 countries where over a
billion users potentially and the fact
of the matter is many of them just don't
have access to credit cards so credit
card support is great but it's just
nowhere near enough and so local forms
of payment is a huge deal for us and we
have a large team working on this around
the world very regularly we're launching
new forms of payment in countries so
what is an example of that so direct
carrier billing is a great example of
that we call it DCP giving users the
ability to make purchases in apps
Kapaa those gems and put it onto your
carrier ball is a huge huge deal for us
so the chart on the right there is
showing what happened one when we
launched direct carrier billing in
Indonesia we didn't even have all the
carriers in Indonesia at that time but
you can see by a growth was grateful
we're always growing our buyer base but
as soon as we launched a local form of
payment
other than cards in the country where
credit cards are not widely used by our
growth winds up for heirs and this is
something that we see over and over and
over recently in Turkey Saudi Arabia all
sorts of countries where credit card
penetration is low launching direct
carrier billing and other local fobs
does a huge deal for the business I
always think this I recommend speak to
your your BD partner if there's a
country that you really care about like
if you're massive in Indonesia make sure
that you know when this happens so you
can take advantage of those sparks and
via growth so DCP is important to us
actually really really proud to say that
we fairly recently crossed over the
hundred carrier partnerships partner
barrier and we actually just carried
right on going with 105 carrier
partnerships around the world in 41
countries and I'm unbelievably that
means more than 600 million actually
quite a lot more than 600 million active
devices have access to direct carrier
billing so it's like a one tap or a few
tap to set up a form of payment on
Google Play
this is a huge job we have a big team
working with carriers setting up the
deals maintaining the deal
working around the world but as you can
see from the previous slide this is
totally worth it so we what the buyer
each team is always out there adding
more direct carrier billing another
great form of payment is the Play gift
cards business so I always talk to
people about gift cards and sites like
the magical form of payment because of
the gives the users the ability to use
whatever form of payment they like the
big one is cash so every single day
every single moment we have people
walking into like a 7-eleven in Tokyo or
a corner store in Indonesia handing over
cash and getting play balance back and
then using that in your apps it's a huge
deal for us it's also a huge operation
there's a like physical retail there's a
lot of regulation around the stuff we've
got a big gift cards team and they do
great work over 500,000 actually way
over 500,000 locations have played gift
cards available to them so you know
almost anywhere in Brazil you can walk
around and get it look play give quite a
few ones so we're constantly like
working to bring more each we actually
have a big team that works on the stuff
they're working with banks they're
working with carriers they're working
with specific local forms of payment in
all sorts of countries it's a huge a
huge job but we take it extremely
seriously and we've got some really cool
local forms of migrants coming in India
in the Netherlands in Germany and Korea
and in other places in the future this
is something that we we care deeply
about we invest deeply this is how we
can bring reach to yourselves on the
rest of the developers and then lastly I
should say that one of the great things
you get on the Google Play platform or
commerce platform is that we already
have a lot of buyers so somebody has
gone along and added a form of payment
added their card and an activator DCB
become comfortable transacting in apps
on other apps and we've got a huge base
of these people and then those they have
become much easier for you to convert in
your own apps so people who have already
made purchases or correlated with the 40
times actually way over 40 times
conversion rate compared to those who
have not purchased in the past so this
is an extremely attractive thing for
developers in the platform the other
thing that lends up happening is we keep
this buyers app terrific their card
expires and we make sure that they renew
their card or their DC they change
carrier and we get them on the new
carrier billing so this is also very big
deal for developers such as yourself but
it's not all about reach reaches
fantastic fantastic but there's also a
lot of optimization and iteration that
goes into this I'm going to hand over to
my mate Mecca and he's gonna tell you a
little bit more about it thanks out sir
so officers right reach is fantastic so
your customers can buy your products in
over 145 different countries around the
world and coverage is great too so
coverage is talking about the different
forms of payment the different ways the
customers can buy your products but
reach and coverage alone are not enough
we want to optimize the purchase
experience so that every one of your
customers has the best possible purchase
experience wherever they happen to be
around the globe so Google Play is a
global commerce platform and that's
something that I want you to really
internalize most of the customers most
of the opportunity for purchasing your
apps and your products is going to exist
outside of the country that your app is
being developed in so I want to talk to
you a little bit about the way that we
think about optimization now we think
about it as applied effort over time we
are constantly improving the platform so
Google Play obviously is a very widely
distributed app over billion users we
push out new changes and improvements to
the purchase flow every single month in
our back-end systems we upgrade every
single week parts of our back-end system
are upgraded every single day the system
is always learning it's always improving
and what that means for you as a
developer is that's how we fulfill the
promise from last year to this year that
our purchase flow is a little bit faster
converts a little bit better and is a
little bit more of the
and so this is what we do for the
platform on your behalf writing code is
fun not writing code and getting the
same result also fun deleting code
that's expert mode but you know we'll
talk about that later
so I want to talk about a little model
that we use to think about optimizing
our purchase flow and this works with
your applications as well now we think
about commerce obviously I love commerce
but there are other ways to monetize in
your application as well this works for
advertising this works for purchases
even outside of commerce but this is the
model that we use we think about
friction and motivation now motivation
is anything that gives your users
incentive to make a purchase so maybe
you have a great content app and users
want to subscribe to see that content no
Game of Thrones spoilers and maybe you
have a great game right and you have in
on items that the user would like to
purchase to advance to the next level
right all of these things are motivation
they give the user incentive to make a
purchase
now friction is anything that can stop
that purchase from happening the fact
friction is also anything that can even
slow that purchase down now some
friction is really obvious if the form
of payment that the user wants to use is
not available well then they can't make
that purchase
that's why gift cards are so important a
little bit less subtle or a little bit
more subtle is things like the number of
clicks so the number of screens that a
user has to go through and that one
makes sense less plates fewer screens
improves conversion now latency and
network connectivity errors again
thinking about a global commerce
platform these ones are really important
now we're here in Mountain View inches
away from Google headquarters our 4G
coverage
and our Wi-Fi is unlimited and unmetered
this is just not the case for most of
your customers around the globe right so
improvements in latency and conversion
have a small impact here in the
developed world but in countries like
Brazil India Indonesia has a huge uplift
just by making your applications more
resilient to adverse networked
situations another even more subtle one
I want to talk about is cognitive load
that's a fancy way of saying how much do
I have to think before making a purchase
the answer should be not much so things
that interfere with this thing's that
increase cognitive load are more
information on the screen that is needed
to complete the purchase we want to keep
the screens as simple as possible yet we
want the customer to be fully informed
when they make a purchase commerce is a
trust relationship you give me money I
give you stuff and if that works out
well we do this again right commerce to
work well is a long-term trust
relationship so you want the users to
have the information to be informed but
you don't want to give them more
information than they need and the way
you solve that with is with good design
design matters so what I mean is for the
UX designers out there moving pixels
around does actually drive up revenue
now pricing pricing a you know is a huge
form of friction that a lot of people
don't think about and this is another
one that I want you to take very
seriously and we're going to talk about
this in detail later I saw the Android
auto Maserati
I want a Maserati who doesn't want a
Maserati that price point is causing me
some friction and so
the items priced at the right point
really helps your users to convert and
we're gonna go into some some examples
Thompson's going to help us with that
pricing stuff is hard but have since
amazing so this old it'll all work out
localizing the purchase flow it's
something that we do is something that
you can do in your apps and it's easy to
say well I don't know all the local
markets I don't know how to make my app
work there but some things are
incredibly simple so something as simple
as in the United States we like to buy
stuff with credit cards in some
countries they like the Vikings with
bank transfer in other countries they
like the Vikings on the carrier bill so
solving the friction point of enabling
customers to purchase that problem is
sold in different ways with different
markets now that's looking at location
as one dimension but there are many
dimensions now everything we've talked
about so far talked about the reach we
talked about the coverage these are all
things that we're doing and it would be
great if you didn't have to do anything
and everything would just work but you
know this is the purchase flow doesn't
begin with Google the motivation doesn't
begin with Google it begins with your
apps and your customers and there are
some things that you can really be
optimizing as well we're going to go
into what some of those examples are and
again this is for commerce in general
right these are commerce fundamentals so
let's talk a little bit about rocket
internet rocket Internet is a global
scale company and they have over a
hundred applications one of their
applications is a food delivery app and
in this food delivery app they analyze
their users they looked at sixty
dimensions location being just one of
them they also looked at session length
cart size what products the customers
were ordering they use Google Analytics
to do this they loaded it up using
bigquery and analyzed it and what they
saw was that they users kind of broke
down into five clusters the top two
clusters
contain just 5% of their users drove 40
percent of their revenue right so you
know you think Pareto principle okay
well then let's student money left let's
just draw everyone on that the
high-value users and kind of focus there
well not quite right the bottom 95%
again that represents your opportunity
that represents your growth that's where
your scale comes from
so what rocket did they divided their
team in half half of the team focused on
high-value users and half of the team
focused on the users who are not yet
high value and what they saw is even
looking at the high value users they saw
something interesting they saw that
these two cohorts behave differently
right you think you're most engaged
users are your highest value the ones
with the long session times and that's
not what they saw what they saw was that
their most high-value customers had
extremely short session times they were
getting in they knew the app they
quartered what they want and they got
out now they had a very high completion
rate of orders right hence why the
revenue was high but they weren't
spending long in the app so optimizing
for them means something different
optimizing for them means adding a
one-click checkout making that fast
session even faster I don't know if
they're allowed to say one thing
checkout maybe less than two click
checkout but so then they looked at the
other cohort the other high-value user
cohort and what they saw is that these
users were doing a lot of repeat
ordering right they were coming in and
they were spending a lot of time in the
order just making the same order that
they made last time so optimizing for
them meant putting something hey here's
that curry bowl you ordered last week
would you like to order it again right
so this is when you think about
optimizing think about optimizing
along many dimensions there's lots of
different toys in this case that use
Google Analytics and bigquery but
there's lots of different ways to do
this I saw some really amazing stuff
from firebase here at i/o don't know if
you guys caught some of those sessions
the Play Store we've had a lot of really
great tools and some of your buildings
are really interesting things that
tensive is doing some interesting things
so there's lots of different ways to do
this but the key point is you should be
doing it and then looking at these users
who are not in the top 95% what they saw
was that when they dug into this 84
percent of those users which were
falling off on the homescreen they
weren't getting any further than the
home screen right why right
so they start digging into this they
started doing UX experimentation right
they started reducing the amount of
information you need it to provide just
to get started again providing too much
data that's another form of friction I
don't want to fill out a form just so I
can see if you're a food delivery app is
good right
so this is what this is what I want you
all to be thinking about when you think
about optimizing your app now another
example is optimizing your business
model how do you monetize but the simple
days used to be how you got free apps
and then by my paid app that wasn't very
great then we're sort of in today's
world was oK we've got the free app and
you've got enough items for
subscriptions right but maybe you ad
supported but I want you to start
thinking about using these different
monetization mechanisms in combination
so logu is a dating app does anyone
familiar with Lomu am I saying that
right
looking and so there's really two
different types of dating apps there's
ones that are really trying to develop
long term connections and those tend to
be subscription type apps and then there
are ones that are much more casual right
you know swipe left swipe right that
kind of thing and those tend to use
in-app billing items so you know buy
super lights or put your government I
done
you know this type of thing what la Lu
notice was that they could combine these
two things to get a good result because
the casual daters were very unlikely to
subscribe right so what they did was
they said well let's offer a cold let's
offer subscription for people looking
for a long-term connection and let's
offer in on items for people looking for
calculating and at work they were able
to monetize these customers that they
weren't able to monetize before but
something amazing happened they noticed
that over time the casual daters 10% of
them subscribed
I became higher our Pugh long-term
connection customers this this gives me
hope right people a lot of people really
do want long-term connection with other
human beings it's not all about just
hooking up right so this is interesting
think about the different models that
you can use to monetize your effort now
we have a promotions team on Google Play
that builds promotions for customers
things like but discount codes coupons
that kind of thing
the mission of that team is the right
offer for the right user in the right
context at scale now underwater apps I
don't know like what's going on here but
they get that mission crystally clear
they've implemented this in their own
app so what they do
again they combine advertising and
in-app purchase items but what they do
is they use the player stats API to
understand the behavior of their users
which users are they going to monetize
through advertising which users are they
going to monetize through in-app
purchasing again in the old days it used
to be get my free version it has at get
my paid version and or upgrade to
freemium it has no ads but why make the
user have to make that conscious choice
why raise the carpet of
how do you bring that down we bring it
down by analyzing the data and making
that understand getting that
understanding without the user having to
tell you anything so they were able to
predict which users were likely to spend
now what do they do with this data the
users that were likely to spend they
decided not to show those users ads and
what they saw was that revenue went up
by fifteen percent don't show ads to the
customers who are about to spend and
again you don't have to ask the users
for this you can understand this from
looking at the data they also did
something else for the users that were
unlikely to ever spend in the act
normally for an in-app purchase type app
that might be a wash
what they decided was to up the
frequency of the ads so that when the
users opened the ad ever open the app
every time they saw one app before it
was something less than one what they
were able to see was they were able to
increase the advertising revenue from
those users by 17% that's pretty awesome
and again not the user doesn't have to
do anything this is understanding your
data understanding your users deeply and
segmenting okay so we've talked a lot
about the different types of
optimization we've talked about reach
and coverage but pricing optimization is
its its own topic I think is deserving
of its own section so tamsin is gonna
help us with that Thank You thanks
makeup
so Mecca and Alistar have just taken us
through all of the things which we're
doing to work so hard to make our play
commerce platform make more money for
you so what I'm going to talk about is
I'll give you some examples of
developers who've really taken advantage
of all of the platforms that we offer to
make more money in the next 10 minutes
or so I'll take you through some
examples of developers who use
creativity they've use localization and
they've more importantly use the
experimentation to increase revenue and
conversion so scope Lee is a fantastic
American games application I know
there's someone in the audience today so
if you have any questions you can hunt
her down scope Lee has over 50 million
downloads worldwide and they are a
role-playing and strategy game and their
recent game as you can see in the screen
is the walking dead now traditionally
RPG and strategy games and I'm sure I
don't need to tell you this I'm sure you
people know a mother ties through in-app
purchasing but Scott Lee had a challenge
how can they increase retention and new
users so why is this important for scope
Lee well when you think about an RPG
strategy game it's really important to
build an ecosystem ecosystem of players
right so that you can create a team
battle ethic out
battle it out against each other who
here plays RPG games I would expect it
from you Phillip good yes excellent so
so what how do they approach this
challenge well because they're great
users of the Google Play platform they
came up with an innovative monetization
technique they introduced a 30-day pass
okay so the really great thing about
this pass was when you downloaded it
when you bought it you got an instant
two hundred and seventy coins okay so
what but then here's the kick up every
time you came back into the game on a
daily basis within that thirty day
period
you got an additional seventy coins so
in effect what they're doing is
incentivizing users to come back and
play the game
and grow that ecosystem so they combined
subscription with in-app purchases to
really grow retention but that's not all
what they found which was really
surprising to them was that their new
users and non paying users increased
what they saw was at one third of all
their purchases of this pack were brand
new users and two-thirds of those were
non-payers long-term non-payers now did
anyone see Mateos talk on Wednesday okay
Philip again good so I would encourage
you to have a look at that live stream
when you go back home but he goes into
more detail about using data to really
understand your audience but in game
language what I've been told by scope is
that if a user doesn't actually spend
money in it between the first one and
seven days or really one at three
they're highly unlikely to ever spend
any money now the name of the game here
I think the presentation is called how
to make money on Google Play so the
scope is a great example because what
they've effectively done is unlock this
long-term non-paying base of users to
create a whole new market now unlocking
new users and long term non spenders is
important for everyone wouldn't you
agree
yeah everyone wants more money more
payers and it's not its most important
in emerging markets who here is from an
emerging market few people excellent
yeah I'm for an emerging market as well
I'm Australian okay so in its emerging
just no one knows about it yet so diff
knob is is a is an example of one of our
partners who really took advantage of
our new lower minimum price floors that
we launched earlier this year now as I
mentioned and make a mention that
Alastair mentioned we're working really
really hard to increase more forms of
payment in more countries so that people
can buy from you and we think it's
really important because we want to
unlock all these these great users for
you
so div mob is a is a great company
they're based in Vietnam so no one knows
more than they do how people in emerging
markets have different abilities to pay
and they're a huge company they've
recently I think they've had about 40
million downloads and they've just
launched their game epic heroes war
which just got nominated top developer
and editors choice so with all the
success you think fantastic they're
doing so well well in fact what they saw
was that they had all these users in
emerging markets they just weren't
buying they weren't paying and if you
think about it before we made the change
on the minimum price floor
it was $0.99 American now if anyone is
from Vietnam here 99 cents
I checked it today is $22,000 that's the
Vietnamese currency now for twenty two
thousand dong you can get a really
really tasty lunch in Vietnam how much
would your lunch cost you today if you
had to pay for it
eight bucks ten bucks is that does that
sound like something you'd pay as a
minimum price to play again so put in
that in that context now dev mob were
desperate to start testing because they
had the data that backed up their their
hypothesis that once you got someone
just buying something just paying
something you could actually grow them
grow their ARPU through cross-selling
upgrading the game and doing more of
these kinds of things so as soon as we
change the system and allow them to
price lower than us and 99 US cents
they started experimenting in Vietnam
Thailand Malaysia Philippines and the
results were outstanding
they created an introductory pass at the
minimum floor and they saw a 300%
increase in pay transactions 300%
increase and best yet they saw that
their base of paying users tripled and
that was after the the blip of promotion
right so we're talking about consistent
result furthermore will these new users
who are pretty happy to now be able to
you know get into the game they saw a
17% increase in retention so retention
monetization all goes together and the
best part is that if you fast forward a
couple of months six out of ten of their
top transaction markets by volume of
transactions and now these sub dollar
price countries so what this is done
it's really open up a huge new market
for them one which weren't paying before
now another fantastic company we love
very much and is in the audience today
is Animoto so ana mocha also were very
very keen to test subdue low pricing
because they again they also knew they
had all these customers in emerging
markets who weren't paying and this was
a fantastic opportunity to try and move
them along the our food ladder now div
mob have over 400 apps live and over 430
million downloads to date so they know
something about testing and pricing div
mob took a different approach sorry and
a mocha took a different approach and
created sachet pricing now with the
sachet prices you could get 100 diamonds
and 5000 coins for the lowest minimum
price in that country and the way they
structured it was quite interesting this
wasn't a regular price wasn't a regular
SKU it was actually a promotional SKU
that was targeted to these users and the
way they promoted it was through native
banners inside the app so native
billboards and posters
and they were very happy with the
results they saw that 90% of all buyers
of the sachet prices were absolutely new
buyers and better yet as yusuf can
confirm 50% of all of those buyers went
on to become repeat purchases and let me
be clear
they went repeatedly buying the cheap
option they were repeatedly buying the
full priced items so you can see that
what's happening here is you're getting
new payers in and you're just taking
them on the upper journey to increase
their value so this really has opened up
new markets increased retention and
increase revenue for these partners now
work using minimum prices can really
help in emerging markets but obviously
you've also got a mature markets to
target right so Sdn is one example of a
games company might be familiar with
over over 700 million downloads across
the world and they're responsible for
the franchise's juice jam cookie jam and
panda pop they've really thought that
localizing pricing could really have a
big impact in some markets so they took
their top markets and they used the
economists Big Mac index and then they
rounded those prices to the users
preferred country price format now let
me break that down so who here knows
about the Big Mac index cool ok for
those of you who may be less familiar
the Big Mac index is basically a Percy
it's a bit of analysis that The
Economist newspaper has done whereas
thank you very much and what it does is
it shows you the comparative price of a
McDonald's hamburger from America to say
Vietnam so you can really get a sense of
because macchesney know they're pretty
smart about these things you can get a
sense of what the prices should be in
that market now when we talk about price
formats what we mean is that you know in
some markets like Korea and Japan they
prefer whole rounded numbers so instead
of 653 yen they prefer 7
so rounded figures now they tested in as
I said they're top markets and what they
saw was quite interesting they saw that
in some markets like Italy in
Switzerland
our PE increased as much as 78 percent
in other markets they saw a neutral
revenue impact such as Korea and Norway
but above the above all across all of
their countries they tested in they saw
a 30% increase in our proof they were
they were really happy with us because
they they kept wanting to do more
testing and as a result they've rolled
these prices out to all of their apps
and games now the lesson here is that
you know a 10% increase or decrease in a
certain country is not going to work for
everyone the lesson here is that we want
you to test your prices in these
different markets and see what works for
your customers in those markets okay so
we've talked about I've talked about
games a lot haven't we talked about
scope ly deep mob and omocha sgn but
it's not just a games companies who are
leading the innovation in pricing one
example of a great app company is
memorize memorize are a leading language
learning application the nature of their
content obviously learning lots of
languages is that they're a global app
and they have a very large proportion of
users from emerging markets now they're
young company so they only actually
launched priced you know propositions
back in July 2015 they just launched
monthly and annual passes so in August
they decided they'd try localizing
prices they used to be in mind the Big
Mac index again and they saw reductions
between 10 and 80 percent on their
prices depending on the country what
they found was a really good impact in
countries like Egypt India Mexico
Ukraine Saudi Arabia above all they saw
a 46 percent in new subscribers
now we've talked a lot about localizing
prices which is great but to back all
this up what's really important is to
have an experimentation mindset so I'm
going to take you through a couple of
examples of partners who do this
extremely well they've really thought
long and hard about the way they present
the price what the price is and then how
its formatted because the key here is
about has anyone heard about
psychological pricing okay it's
basically if anyone's been to a
restaurant on a date you know you don't
sure you choose the cheapest wine you
choose the second cheapest wine don't
tell anyone
and so this is the idea that you want to
create this idea of value you want to
create a reference point in the users
mind so that they go well I'm cook at
that lower priced one and there's that
expensive one but then one in the middle
looks really good and so this is the
kind of thing we're talking about here
now P cursor is an excellent app they do
their global leaders in brain training
and they know that they need to really
listen to their users continue to test
and iterate to stay ahead of the
competition so what they did was they
tested two different value propositions
to see how they would impact conversion
and revenue the first they tested was
how can they similar to the ones we
talked about earlier how can they
actually get non-payers to start paying
in this instance they ran up to a B test
where they said what would happen if
when the user gets to the point where
they hit subscribe instead they go they
and they back out and they cancel so
what peaked up did was presenting a
screen that said Oh before you go we'll
give you a 20% discount if you subscribe
today
this actually resulted in a 25% increase
in those people who saw the screen
subscribing so never say never the
second thing they tested was how to
increase our poo now as I mentioned or
maybe I didn't mention they had a
monthly and an annual subscription well
they wanted to test was a lifetime
subscription so your I just said about
creating a reference point in people's
mind and that sense of value the
lifetime subscription was three times
the price of the annual subscription but
if you think about the kind of content
it is people have an altruistic view
that they're going to really improve
their brain they're gonna smash it out
well they found was that ten percent now
of all subscribers are lifetime
subscribers and here's the the kicker
I'm sure for you as app developers cash
flows really important having this
lifetime subscription has increased
their return on acquisition cost by 30%
it's coming at 30% faster because
they're getting more cash flowing
quicker so consider things like this
when you when you're pricing memorize
have also done some interesting stuff
around psychological pricing if anyone
knows we actually launched quarterly
subscriptions in September last year I
was very excited so memorize already had
monthly and annual subscriptions and
they they were very keen to test
quarterly again you know learning a
language is a announced we're tsuki no I
really wanted to do it it's a still
fulfilling enjoyable task so what they
found was that well first of all they're
a bit concerned that people would stop
buying the annual and moved to the
quarterly but what they found was that
actually the people who were usually
buying the monthly started buying the
quarterly and there was no
cannibalization in the annual and this
resulted in a seventy two percent lift
in RP plus they saw a 33% more users
they also tested point-in-time messaging
so you know i talked about when pig had
that back out flow message memorized it
a similar thing but instead of targeting
non-payers memorized were seeing if they
could increase our prove existing
subscribers so they targeted monthly and
quarterly users or subscribers and when
they're having a really good learning
experience when they're really smashing
it out winning all their you know their
tests memorize will give them a a
call-to-action hey you're doing so well
why don't you just upgrade to the Annual
Pass and save some money and this
resulted in a doubling of RP for those
users so peak and memorize the two
really good examples of developers who
really really employed price
experimentation to grow revenue and
conversion now the final example I'll
talk about is interesting because it's
not about the price itself and it's not
about reference pricing it's about how
do you describe the value that you're
offering users to the cash you're asking
for now is anyone used fantastic good
okay so fantastic have 17 amps live in
the app store if you know they started
out as a premium offering and about a
year and a half ago they moved to a
subscription model so conversions really
important for them now what they saw
from their data was that people were
dropping off on that final screen on the
final purchase screen and they had a
suspicion that maybe if they changed the
way they presented a copy that would
have an impact so the original screen
had all the little features listed out
in great detail so what they tested was
having just the one key feature called
out in a cleaner simpler screen this
resulted in a one hundred and three
percent lift in conversion so you can
see that testing different price
propositions representations and
descriptions can really increase
conversion in revenue so today we've
covered quite a bit we've talked about
how our goal in life is to make sure
that every single Android user in the
world can buy your content no matter
where they are and what format they want
to pay in we've talked about how we want
to remove all the friction from the
payment flow and we've given you some
examples of developers who've used
creativity and leverage our platform in
different ways to increase revenue now
one thing I'm going to call out now we
mentioned analytics before but all of
the developers we talked about today use
experimentation and data to drive their
product pricing
proposition decisions and they all think
about how much can the users in
different countries that I serve afford
now the Big Mac index is free you can go
and have a look at it today it's no
problem
so I'd really encourage you to consider
these things we've talked about today
and apply them to your own app because I
know I can speak on behalf of these guys
we're so excited to see what you'll do
next
thank you